THE RAZA EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MAN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TELEVOTE. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REALM AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR CHOI BALK.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING PLEASE
AND WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR TROUBLE. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS. LET US BRING OUR MINDS
BODIES AND HEARTS INTO GOD'S
PRESENCE AS WE LISTEN TO THE
WORDS OF A SONG BY LIVI RODDICK
RODERICK. WE SENT ON THE EDGE
OF A CLIFF IN THE DEEPEST NIGHT
WE'VE EVER SEEN. PEOPLE LOOKING
FOR LIGHT PEOPLE WHO CHERISH
THE DREAM. BUT THE LIGHTS
SHINING OUT FROM OUR EYES AND
THE JEANS RESTING DEEP IN OUR
SOULS. IT'S LOVE THAT WE NEED
TO KEEP US FROM FALLING IT'S
LOVE THAT WE ALREADY KNOW. STAY
LOW TO THE GROUND LIVE CLOSE TO
THE EARTH. DON'T STRAY VERY FAR
FROM YOUR SOUL IT'S THAT SIMPLE
THINGS. IT'S THAT SIMPLE THINGS
SHOWS THE REASON WE'RE HERE AND
IT'S SIMPLE THINGS KEEPING US
WHOLE. THE TEMPLES ARE FALLING
AROUND US WE STAND STRONG AND
FIERCE WHERE THEY'VE BEEN. I'VE
I NEVER HAVE SEEN A HOLIER SITE
THAN A PERSON WHO SINGS IN
THEIR DREAM. OUR BLOOD IS THE
RIVER OF LIFE OUR JOY IS THE
SUN ON THE PLANT. ALL OF THE
LOVE THAT IS INSIDE THIS HEART
IS MORE THAN ONE PERSON CAN
STAND FOR MELO TO THE- THIS IS
FROM LIBBY RODERICK LOW TO THE
GROUND. LOVING GOD IN ALL OF
LIFE'S JOYS SORROWS AND
DISAPPOINTMENTS MAY WE NOT
FORGET THE DREAMS OF OUR
MOTHERS AND FOR MOTHERS. MAY WE
CONFIRM BY OUR LIVES THAT WE
ARE OUR ANCESTORS WILDEST
DREAMS A MAN. MY COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THE IT IS WHICH STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
RAMON AND SENATOR STORER STORY
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WILL SAY
GOOD MORNING TO THOSE TWO
SENATORS MOVING ON TO SIGN FOR
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY MEETING READ.
MARCH OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES THERE ARE NONE.
YEAH MOVING OUT TO
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING DOWN THE
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH EIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL TWO OH
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS
FIVE OR ONE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
NINETY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS ONE HUNDRED WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIVE OH
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS AND
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU NOW
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT SENATOR BATES ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE. ITEMS
NINE AND TEN H. IF YOU'RE READY
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I AM NOT A WILL TAKE
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF SHIP ON.
KOTHARI AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS
POSITION SHE WAS SERVING AS
DIRECTOR OF THE MARIPOSA COUNTY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. SHE IS ALSO A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTY WORKERS
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH
ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT. KERN
ST NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A FILE ITEM
NINE. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. I BAKER I FOR
JUST HI BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CORTES C. HI DALLY. DALLY FIVE
DODD. FIVE ZERO SEVEN I EGGMAN.
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HURTADO
JONES FIVE KAMLAGER FIVE
LAYERED HI LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE.
HI MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TELEVOTE I
CAN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER I
LAKE COUNTY HI WIENER. I WILL
HI. M. SIX GROVE HI. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN. FIVE
HUESO. HURTADO HI. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED AND NOW MOVING THE
FILE ITEM TEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF ANTI YOU
DRANK AS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION PRIOR TO THIS
ROLE SHE SERVED AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTING CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AND AS CHIEF
COUNSEL SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE BOTTOM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
FIVE BASE. I BAKER FIVE
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTES E. HI DALLY.
FIVE DODD. FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
HI GROSS. HI HERTZBERG I HUESO.
HURTADO HI JONES HI KAMLAGER HI
WHERE'D I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MILLION. I
NEWMAN BY NIELSEN. FIVE A
CHIRLA BOTH. FIVE PAN I
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
I SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE HI MY
COUNTY FIVE WIENER. HI WILK HI
HI. BERSERKER PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. HUESO. VICE
SEVEN NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
WAS CONFIRMED ABOUT MEMBERS
REMOVING THE SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE FILE ITEMS
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO.
SENATOR BORDERS ARE YOU
PREPARED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- OF MAN CHECKERED
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR GORGEOUS
RELATIVE TO COMMEMORATING THE
TWO HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
GREEK INDEPENDENCE. REGULATORY
RESIDENTS AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTEEN
COMMEMORATING THE TWO HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF GREEK
INDEPENDENCE. GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY CELEBRATED ANNUALLY IN
GREECE ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
COMMEMORATING THE START OF THE
WAR OF GREEK INDEPENDENCE IN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE. FOR ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS GREECE WAS
UNDER THE REIGN OF THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE. ORTHODOX GREEKS WERE
GRANTED FEW RIGHTS AS SUBJECTS
UNDER OTTOMAN RULE. THE GREEK
ORTHODOX CHURCH PLAYED A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN THE
PRESERVATION OF NATIONAL
IDENTITY THE DEVELOPMENT OF
GREEK SOCIETY AND THE
RESURGENCE OF GREEK PATRIOTISM.
THE GREEK REVOLT BEGAN ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE WHEN BISHOP THURMOND ALSO
ABOUT THAT US RAISE THE FLAG OF
REVOLUTION OVER THE MONASTERY
OF ALL YOUR LOVE IT ON IN THE
PELOPONNESE. JUST AS THE
REVOLUTION APPEARED TO BE ON
THE VERGE OF FAILURE. GREAT
BRITAIN FRANCE AND RUSSIA
INTERVENED IN THE CONFLICT. THE
GREEK STRUGGLE HAD ELICITED
STRONG SYMPATHY IN EUROPE
INCLUDING INTELLECTUALS AND
ARTISTS SUCH AS THE ENGLISH
POET LORD BYRON. THE REVOLUTION
ENDED IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE
WHEN THE TREATY DETERMINED
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT GREEKS
STATE. COLLEAGUES GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS MORE THAN
JUST ESTABLISHING GREECE AS AN
INDEPENDENT STATE. GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS ABOUT THE
LASTING VALUES A CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT HELLENISTIC CULTURE HAS
BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA IN LAW
MEDICINE EDUCATION SPORTS THE
ARTS DEMOCRACY IN ARCHITECTURE.
EVEN AS BUILDING DERIVES ITS
ROOTS FROM GREEK ARCHITECTURE.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A GREEK
HERITAGE IN FACT THE GREEK WORD
EUREKA OR GREEK I'VE FOUND HAS
BEEN THE MODEL ON OUR STATE
SEAL SINCE EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE.
REPORTER HAS ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED MY LIFE MY FAMILY MY
WIFE'S FAMILY ARE BOTH FROM
GREECE I GREW UP IN A
TRADITIONAL GREEK AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLD I WAS A FULBRIGHT
SCHOLAR IN GREECE AND WORKED.
AT A THINK TANK IN ATHENS. THE
CONSUL GENERAL OF SAN FRANCISCO
EVEN ADMINISTER MY OATH FOR
DOCTORAL STATUS. AS GREECE IN
THE UNITED STATES CONTINUE TO
STAND TOGETHER AS FRIENDS AND
ALLIES LET US RECOGNIZE OUR
SHARED LOVE FOR FREEDOM LIBERTY
AND INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS. WHEN THE
ISLAND OF CRETE WAS INVADED BY
**** GERMANY IN NINETEEN FORTY
ONE. AND GREEK DEMOCRACY WAS
THREATENED ONCE AGAIN. GREEK
CIVILIANS DEMONSTRATE THE
RESOLVE AND STRENGTH BY DOING
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO DEFEND THEIR
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY. WINSTON
CHURCHILL ONCE FAMOUSLY SAID.
WE WILL NOT SAY THAT GREEKS
FOUGHT LIKE HEROES. INSTEAD BUT
THAT HEROES FIGHT LIKE GREEKS.
COLLEAGUES DEMOCRACY IN AMERICA
IS IN PERIL. LET US LOOK TO THE
LESSONS AND LEARN FROM THE
EXPERIENCES OF THE GREEKS IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT
DEMOCRATIC VALUES IN OUR
INCREASINGLY CHALLENGED NATION.
WE TOO MUST DEFEND THE VALUES
OF OUR GREAT DEMOCRACY AGAINST
ENEMIES BOTH FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. LET THIS RESOLUTION
BE A GESTURE TO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
GREECE HAS GIVEN OR GOLDEN
STATE. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I-
PROUDLY JOIN IN THE- ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION- I LIVE IN A
HOUSEHOLD THAT- MY SIGNIFICANT
OTHERS FATHER IS FROM THE
ISLAND OF HEROES. AND FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS LIVED ON THE
OCEAN IS A GREEK SHIP CAPTAIN
AND I AM CONSTANTLY REMINDED IN
IN MY DAILY LIFE FROM ATHENA
GRACE OUR DAUGHTER TO THE-
DAILY REMINDER OF HOW MANY
WORDS COME FROM GREEK ORIGIN
LIKE WE'VE SEEN IN THE MOVIES-
TO NOT WINDEX BUT OTHER TYPES
OF CANCER CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
IT'S- THE GREEK CULTURE IS AS
WAS EXPRESSED BY THE- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO. IS AT
THE CORE OF OUR DEMOCRACY AND
THE FIGHT OF FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS- IS HUGE COMPARED TO WHAT
WE'VE DONE HERE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND SO I JUST WANT TO HONOR THE
CULTURE HONOR MY HOUSEHOLD
OWNER MARCUS. DAIS AND- TO
STAND. STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER THIS OF THE VERY ON THE
SIDE. IN NINETEEN NINE SENATOR
BORDERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND COLLEAGUES I AM ASK YOUR I
VOTE AND HOPEFULLY ALL OF YOU-
RECEIVED. THE GIFT OF THE MAHDI
AND THE OFF SESSION I CAN GIVE
YOU BETTER INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW
TO PROPERLY IMBIBED. WITH THAT-
MISTER PRESIDENT- I WAS ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
FIVE BASE FIVE BECKER I PORCHES.
I BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY FIVE DODD. HI
TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
BY JONES HI KAMLAGER. FIVE
LAYERED HI LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. FIVE MILLION HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. FIVE HOTEL
OF BOTH HI PAM HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI
I'M BURKE HI LAKE COUNTY FIVE
WIENER. HI WILK HI. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO. SENATOR GONZALEZ
ARE YOU PREPARED YES MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
RELATIVE TO CESAR CHAVEZ DAY.
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT THOUSAND
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN
WHICH CALLS UPON ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OBSERVE MARCH
THIRTY FIRST AS DAY OF PUBLIC
SERVICE IN HONOR OF THE BIRTH
AND LEGACY OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND
LABOR ACTIVISM CHAVIS. GROWING
UP MEXICAN AMERICAN WE OFTEN
DON'T GET TO LEARN MUCH ABOUT
HISTORIC FIGURES THAT LOOK LIKE
US THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE LEGACY OF SENSE
OF TRAVIS. I THOUGHT I KNEW
FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLES OF THE
NATION'S POOREST AND MOST
POWERLESS WORKERS WHO LABOR TO
PUT FOOD ON OUR NATION'S TABLES
WERE OFTEN GOING HUNGRY
THEMSELVES. HE DEDICATED HIS
LIFE WORK TO WHAT HE CALLED
LIKE OUTSIDE. AND SUCCESSFULLY
INCREASED PUBLIC AWARENESS OF
FARMWORKERS WORKING CONDITIONS
AND WORK TO BETTER THEIR LIVES
TO COUNTLESS STRIKES BOYCOTTS
MARCHES AND FAST. EVEN THOUGH
SAYS THAT CHáVEZ FACE SOME
DEFEATS HE NEVER STOPPED HIS
PEACEFUL BATTLES ON BEHALF OF
THE FARMWORKERS WHO SHARED HIS
LIFE WITH. TODAY FARMWORKERS
CONTINUE TO PUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLES AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THROUGH THIS VERY DIFFICULT
PANDEMIC. THE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THAT WE ENJOY IN OUR
DAILY LIVES ARE PRODUCED BY
FARMWORKERS WHO OFTEN INJURED
AND LONG HOURS OF BREAK BACK
BACKBREAKING WORK. AND STILL
FACE CHALLENGES SUCH AS AN
ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT OF
PESTICIDES SAFETY AND LABOR
PROTECTION LAWS IN THE FIELDS.
OF LEGISLATORS ARE KASA IS TO
LOOK AFTER OUR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AND BETTER THE
LIVES OF EVERY CALIFORNIANS IN
THE SPIRIT OF SYSTEM CHáVEZ.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
AND WALKED OUTSIDE. TO HONOR AN
APPLE THE LEGACY OF SENSE OF
TRAVIS. AND RECOGNIZE THE
CONTINUED STRUGGLES OF ALL OF
OUR FROM FARM WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AS WE CONTINUE TO
OVERCOME THIS PANDEMIC. IN THE
SPIRIT OF CESA CHAVEZ I SAY
SEIZE UP WITH IT. WE WILL GET
THROUGH IT C. SEPARATING. YES
WE CAN AND WE WILL THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON S. R. SEVENTEEN.
ANY ADDITIONAL DID BETTER
DISCUSSION ON. THIS RESOLUTION
CENTER WINNER. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ISE IS BY CHAIR
THE- THE JEWISH. TO SUPPORT
SENATE FOR THE SEVENTEEN- WE'RE
PROUD TO HONOR CESAR CHAVEZ
TODAY MAN WHO WORKED EVERYDAY
TO FIGHT. FOR THE DIGNITY OF
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS- THIS IS
A CHAVEZ ALSO HAD A CONNECTION
TO THE JEWISH. COMMUNITY AND
WE'RE PROUD OF THAT
RELATIONSHIP. AS RELATIVELY NEW
IMMIGRANTS JEWISH TRADE WORKERS
PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN THE
RISE OF THE LABOR MOVEMENT IN
THE LATE NINETEENTH CENTURY AND
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY. JEWISH
LABOUR ACTIVISTS SAMUEL GOMPERS
WAS THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
AFL- RUNNING THE UNION FOR
ALMOST FORTY YEARS AT THE SAME
TIME THE UNITED HEBREW TRADES.
BOTH ITS POWER TELLING ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX JEWISH UNIONS
UNDER ITS UMBRELLA. I JUST
WANTED TO CHAVEZ STARTED TO
ORGANIZE TO FIGHT OPPRESSION OF
LARGELY LATINO- AND ALSO
FILIPINO FARMWORKERS. MANY
JEWISH LEADERS ROSE TO ITS SIDE
IN SOLIDARITY SEVERAL ORTHODOX
RABBIS URGE THEIR CONGREGATIONS
NOT TO BUY A NON UNION GRADES
DECLARING THEM OSHA- MEETING
UNCLEAN BECAUSE THEY CAME FROM
EXPLOITED LABOR. RABBI JOSEPH
GLAZER EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CENTRAL CONFERENCE OF
AMERICAN RABBIS SAID QUOTE
UNTIL THE PEOPLE WHO STOOP AND
SQUAT. AND GO THROUGH ALL KINDS
OF HELL OUT THERE IN THE FIELDS
ARE TREATED RIGHT. THOSE GRADES
ARE TRAFFORD TRADE. MEETING NOT
KOSHER. TRAGICALLY SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD MAN FREEMAN WAS THE
FIRST PERSON TO LOSE HER LIFE.
ON A FARM WORKER PICKET LINE
SHE WAS A COLLEGE STUDENT FROM
BOSTON WHO TRAVEL TO FLORIDA.
TO JOIN A STRIKE AGAINST
TALISMAN SUGAR COMPANY. I WAS
KILLED BY A TRUCK CRASH IN THE
PICKET LINE. CHAVEZ'S WIFE
HELEN ONE SHARE THIS STORY FROM
WHEN THEIR UNION WAS GAINING
MOMENTUM. AFTER OPENING SEVERAL
DONATION CHECKS HER SISTER
TURNED TO HER AND SAID HIS
SISTER LOOK ALL THESE PEOPLE.
HAVE THE SAME FIRST NAME ROBERT.
THE VOICES A JEWISH OF THE-
PREVALENT THE FARMWORKERS
MOVEMENT- THE CESAR CHAVEZ- AND
BEGAN- AND CESAR EVEN BEYOND TO
HOST. PASSOVER SEDERS- THE
JEWISH VALUE OF FIGHTING FOR
JUSTICEIS NEVER STOPPED AT THE
GATES OF OUR OWN COMMUNITY.
TODAY AS WE HONOR CESAR CHAVEZ
WE RECOGNIZE THE LONGSTANDING
JEWISH LATINO PARTNERSHIP TO
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
PARTNERSHIP ALWAYS CONTINUES
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PRAYER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'M HONORED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS ARE
SEVENTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZES
THESE ARE SOME OF THE STATE I
THINK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LONG
BEACH FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION
FOR. THE CALIFORNIA NIGHT OF
FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
ASIAN AND LATINO COMMUNITIES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE WARY AT
LEON ALONG WITH PHILIP VERACRUZ
PETER VELASCO CYNTHIA BONTA AND
MANY FILIPINO FARMWORKERS
INITIATED THE INFAMOUS DELANO.
LAKE STREET. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE MOVEMENTS
EITHER. LED THE MEXICAN
FARMWORKERS AND JOIN FORCES
WITH THE FILIPINO FARMWORKERS.
THE SHOP IS UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPORTANCE OF UNITY AND TIP THE
SCALES IN FAVOR OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. THIS PARTNERSHIP LED
TO THE CREATION OF WHAT WE KNOW
TODAY IS THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION. CESAR CHAVEZ DAY
AS A REMINDER THAT WE ARE ALL
IN THIS TOGETHER. SOLIDARITY
WORKS IS A REMINDER THAT WE CAN
FIGHT AGAINST INJUSTICES AND
ACHIEVE GREAT THINGS WHEN WE
HELP EACH OTHER AND SUPPORT
EACH OTHER. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT VOTE IN FAVOR OF
SR SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IT IS MY HONOR TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTEEN. THE THIRD CHAVEZ
LIFE SERVES AS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE INDIVIDUAL
CAN IMPACT GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE. THE FORGE NATIONAL
COALITIONS OF UNIONS CHURCH
GROUPS STUDENTS MINORITIES AND
CONSUMERS THE STAND WITH
FARMWORKERS THROUGH THE
POWERFUL USE OF NONVIOLENCE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF THE
MOST. BALL NOBLE AND VALUABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE FARMWORKERS
ONE RIGHTS INCLUDING THE RIGHT
TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN. TODAY
THE ROLE OF FARMWORKERS IS JUST
AS VITAL TO THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S IT WAS ONE SINCE I
BEGAN HIS STRUGGLE. OUR
FARMWORKERS CONTINUE TO FEED
OUR STATE AND OUR NATION. SINCE
I USED TO SAY IT'S IRONIC THAT
THOSE WHO TOIL THE SOIL
CULTIVATE AND HARVEST THE
FRUITS VEGETABLES AND OTHER
FOODS THAT FILL YOUR TABLES
WITH ABUNDANCE. HAVE NOTHING
LEFT FOR THEMSELVES. I
PERSONALLY KNOW WHAT HE MEANT
BY THAT. I GREW UP WORKING IN
THE FIELDS OF MY PARENTS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS I PICKED
GRAPES AND COTTON PEACHES
OLIVES AND MUCH MORE. WE WORKED
FROM SUN UP TO SUN DOWN AND
MANY TIMES WE DIDN'T MAKE
ENOUGH TO EAT AND PUT A ROOF
OVER OUR HEADS FOOD PITCH THE
TENT OR SLEPT IN THE BACK OF
OUR FLATBED TRUCK. MY LATE
HUSBAND MIGUEL AND HIS FAMILY
AND I KNEW BUT JOIN THE
FARMWORKERS MOMENT. THEY WENT
ON STRIKE. AND ENDED UP GETTING
EVICTED FROM THE SHACK ON THE
GROWERS PROPERTY. CESA CHAVEZ
INSPIRED ME TO DEDICATE MY LIFE.
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE TO CHANGE
THEIR OWN LIVES THAT'S WHY FOR
MOST OF MY LIFE I'VE BEEN AN
ORGANIZER GARMENT WORKERS HOTEL
WORKERS IMMIGRANT WORKERS
WORKING PEOPLE. SAYS THAT
INSPIRED AN ENTIRE GENERATION
OF YOUNG AND OLD TO BE
ACTIVISTS HE ADVOCATED FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT AND LGBT Q.
RIGHTS LONG BEFORE IT WAS
ACCEPTABLE. HE CONNECTED WITH
DR KING AS COMMITTED
PRACTITIONERS OF NONVIOLENT
TOOLS LIKE STRIKES BOYCOTTS AND
MARCHES. IN FACT TO DISLIKE THE
MOST EXPLOITED BLACK SANITATION
WORKERS BECAME THE CAUSE FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS SO
FARMWORKERS BECAME THE CAUSE
FOR LATINOS. I HAD THE FORTUNE
TO MEET AND TALK WITH ASAD
SEVERAL TIMES BUT I REMEMBER
ONCE WAS WHAT ARE. THE MOST.
MEMORABLE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WE ALLEN I VISITED WOULD SET
ASIDE AFTER DAYS INTO HIS LAST
FAST OF THIRTY SIX DAYS TO
PROTEST PESTICIDES. HE HAD
REALLY STARTED TO FEEL THE
HUNGER PAINS. AND SAID THAT HE
HAD HAD A VERY STRANGE DREAM.
WE ASKED WILL WHAT WAS THAT.
AND HE SAID THAT HE DREAMED OF
EATING TACOS THE CARD NOW SAW
THEM. NO OF COURSE HE CHUCKLED.
BECAUSE HE WAS SUCH A DEVOTED
VEGAN. IF WE WANT TO HONOR SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ LET'S HONOR THE
SACRIFICES FARMWORKERS MAKE TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS IF WE
WANT TO HONOR SAYS OUR JOB IS
LET'S USE OUR POWERS
LEGISLATORS. TO MAKE SURE
FARMWORKERS AND ALL
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES ARE TO
DO WITH DIGNITY'S. GOOD GOOD
WAGES HEALTH CARE SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS AND REAL EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. FINALLY THE LATINO
CAUCUSES PRODUCES KEPT
COMMEMORATIVE CARD AND FACE
MASK WITH THE UFW EAGLE. THE
SYMBOL OF THE RESILIENCY OF THE
FARMWORKER LABOR MOVEMENT.
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND UMAN
RIGHTS. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THE SENATOR FROM LONG
BEACH AND THEN BY SAYING GIVE
US AS A TRAVIS ELEVEN YEAR ON
THE CAMPESINOS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER. THE NEW OF
THE MY DESIGN YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE IS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. SEVENTEEN TO
HONOR THE OBSERVANCE OF SISTER
SERVICES BIRTHDAY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST AND I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM LONG BEACH FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AS WE ARE FAMILIAR
SAYS ARE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MANY OTHERS INCLUDING DELORES
WORKER WHO WE WILL CELEBRATE IN
APRIL. IMPROVED LABOR RIGHTS
WAGES AND LIVES OF OUR FOOD
SYSTEM WORKERS. THAT WORK WAS
NECESSARY BECAUSE FARMWORKERS
THE MOST ESSENTIAL OF WORKERS
IF WE THINK ABOUT HOW WE ARE
ALL DEPENDENT ON FOOD.
INTRODUCED THEN PICKED BY
FARMWORKERS THEY WERE EXCLUDED
FROM OUR NATION'S LABOR
PROTECTION LAWS SO IN THE TIME
OF THAT EARLY ORGANIZING.
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS IN ANY
FARMWORKERS WAS EXCLUDED FROM
THOSE LABOR PROTECTION LAWS
THAT IS CHANGED. NO PROXIMATE
LI ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIA'S
FARM WORKERS OR WOMEN THERE ARE
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND FEMALE FARMWORKERS AND
THESE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND ALL
FARMWORKERS AND ALL OF US ARE
BETTER OFF PROCESS ORDERS WORK.
AND THE WORK OF ALL OF THE
ORGANIZERS WHO IMPROVED THE
CONDITIONS FOR FARMWORKERS AND
DOES FOR OTHER WORKERS. BEYOND
THAT SAYS SOURCE LEADERSHIP
INSPIRED GENERATIONS OF
ACTIVISTS. GROWING UP IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I AM GOING
TO CATHOLIC SCHOOL ONE OF THE
PRIESTS IN OUR- HELLO MY
FAMILY- CHICKEN IN FACT IS
ALMOST ONE OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND WE REFERRED TO HIM
AS OUR UNCLE. HIS NAME WAS
FATHER PASCHAL HARDY ALSO KNOWN
AS PASCHAL THE RASCAL. PASCHAL
HARDY WAS ONE OF THE PRIESTS
WHO WORKED WITH SAYS OUR
SERVICE AND THE FARMWORKERS NOW
I THINK I HAD MY PARENTS FULLY
UNDERSTOOD FATHER HARDY'S
INVOLVEMENT MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE ALLOWED HIM TO TAKE MY
SISTERS AND I TO THE MARCHES
THAT THEY BROUGHT HE BROUGHT US
TO. IN SUPPORT OF THE
FARMWORKERS SO I THINK IT WAS-
I WAS SIX OR SEVENTH GRADE AND
I WOULD BE IN DOWNTOWN LA
MARCHING WITH FATHER HARDY AND
OF COURSE MY SIBLINGS AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOOD WORK THAT
SISTER SHOPPERS WAS DOING. AND
LATER WHEN I WAS ON THE
BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL FIVE
INTRODUCED THE RESOLUTION
RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT THE
SECOND GREAT BOYCOTT IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES. IN
SOLIDARITY AND LATER THE
STRAWBERRY BOYCOTT IN THE
LEGACY OF HIS WORK CONTINUES TO
MOTIVATE THOSE WHO ARE FIGHTING
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS TODAY.
INCLUDING ESSENTIAL PROTECTIONS
FOR FEMALE FARM WORKERS 80% OF
FEMALE FARM WORKERS REPORT
EXPERIENCING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND OTHERS HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON THE JOB. THIS
IS OUR SERVICE HOLIDAY I HOPE
WE CAN ALL RECOMMIT TO THE
VISION SAYS OUR HAT FOR FOOD
SYSTEM WORKERS FOR FAIR PAY FOR
DIGNIFIED AND SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS AND. THE RIGHT TO
ORGANIZE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SAN CALM WATER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S.
R. SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
THANK THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
LONG BEACH FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THAT'S A SHOT AS FAR
AS AN ACTIVIST AGAINST
OPPRESSIVE CAPITALISM. AND IN
THAT ACTIVISM AND THROUGHOUT
HIS LONG LIFE HE FOUND
SOLIDARITY AND SUPPORT FROM
BLACK PEOPLE. THE BLACK PANTHER
PARTY DURING SISI'S CHAVEZ AND
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS IN IT
UNLIKELY ALLIANCE TO FIGHT
AGAINST SAFEWAY IN OAKLAND SAFE
WAYS PUNITIVE PRACTICES. THEY
PATRONIZE OTHER LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOOD STORES AND
SUCCESSFULLY BOYCOTTED SAFEWAY
UNTIL ITS CLOSURE. THE STUDENT
NONVIOLENT COORDINATING
COMMITTEE JOINED USW AND A TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILE MARCH
FROM DELANO TO SACRAMENTO TO
PROTEST THE EXPLOITATION OF
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. CHERYL
AND BRUCE AND HER LITTLE
DAUGHTER SICKENING KAMLAGER
JOINED THE FIGHT IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE U. F. W. BY BOYCOTTING
GRAPES. AND NOT PURCHASING THEM
FOR ALMOST A DECADE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH SENSORS OFFICE
IN FACT I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
A GREAT PLUS I WAS NOT ALLOWED
TO EAT IT FOR SO LONG.
CENSORSHIP AND SALAS IN MARTIN
LUTHER KING SUPPORT AND
STRUGGLE. EARLY ON IN THE DORMS
STRIKE HE ACTUALLY SENT A
TELEGRAM DOESN'T CHAVEZ WRITING
OUR SEPARATE STRUGGLES REALLY
ARE ONE. I STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM
OR DIGNITY AND FOR HUMANITY. IN
FACT IN DOUBLE ACP THE NATIONAL
URBAN LEAGUE SNCC SCLC AND SO
MANY OTHER BLACK ORGANIZATIONS.
FOR DECADES HAVE HAD A STRONG
STALWART ALLIANCE. WITH FEATHER
CHAVEZ AND THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS MOVEMENT SO AS WE RISE
IN SUPPORT AND VOTE FOR S. R.
SEVENTEEN LET'S ALSO COMMIT.
THE CONTINUING TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY FOR FARMWORKERS TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE. TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
PROTECTIONS TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE HOUSING IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE CREATING. A
BUSINESS THAT DIGNIFY IS THE
WORKERS WHO MAKE IT A REALITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATE
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SR SEVENTEEN AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH- FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT IS SO IMPORTANT IN
MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES
MMHM SUPPLIED US WITH THE MASS
TODAY GOOD KNOWLEDGE IS VERY
SPECIAL BIRTHDAY. BUT I ALSO
RISE TODAY IN RECOGNITION OF
THE VETERAN UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN NAME HAPPENS TO BE
CAESAR CHAVEZ WHO SERVED THE
NAVY WITH HONOR AND DIGNITY
THIS CHARGE RETURN TO HOME TO
TAKE CARE OF WHAT HE FELT
NEEDED TO BE DONE THE CHANGE
AMERICA THE CHANGE CALIFORNIA
AND HE'S DONE THAT. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO QUOTE JUST A COUPLE OF
WORDS IF I MAY MR PRESIDENT.
COMMISSIONERATE IT'S IRONIC
THAT THOSE WHO TILL THE SOIL
CULTIVATE THE HARVEST THE
FRUITS THE VEGETABLES AND OTHER
FOODS THAT FILL YOUR TABLES
WITH ABUNDANCE HAVE NOTHING
LEFT FOR THEMSELVES WE MUST
REMEMBER THOSE WHO WORK FOR US
WE MUST PROTECT THEM AS WELL
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS TODAY I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTEEN WHICH
REMEMBERS AND HONORS THE
BIRTHDAY AND LEGACY OF CESAR
CHAVEZ CESAR CHAVEZ DAY IS NOT
JUST A DAY OFF FOR ME IT'S A
DAY OF REFLECTION. IT'S A DAY
TO HONOR NOT ONLY HIM BUT ALL
pCURRENTLY WORKING REALLY HARD
TO PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLE AND
ENSURE THAT DURING THESE COLD
AT TIMES THAT WE HAVE FOOD AND
THAT WE ARE HEALTHY. MY FATHER
FIRST CAME TO THE UNITED STATES
AS OF US THAT'LL- HE WAS A
MEXICAN LABOR WHO WAS GIVEN
PERMISSION TO WORK IN THE STATE
AS A SEASONAL AGRICULTURAL
WORKER FOR A LIMITED TIME. I
REMEMBER HIM TELLING US STORIES
STORIES OF HARD LABOR. COLD
NIGHTS BLISTERS ON HIS HANDS.
HE EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND. BUT
MY FATHER ALSO SHARED SO MANY
GOOD PEOPLE HE MET ALONG THE
WAY WHO ARE KIND AND HELPED HIM.
IT'S NOT EASY AND WE MUST
ALWAYS RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK
SELF SACRIFICE AND PERSEVERANCE
FARMWORKERS GO THROUGH. TO
PROVIDE FOOD ON OUR TABLE. THE
STRUGGLE FOR FAIR TREATMENT.
FOR WAGES AND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. STILL IS A STRUGGLE TODAY.
BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT A
GOOD FIGHT BECAUSE THEY DESERVE
BETTER THANK YOU AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTESE. BOTH FIGURES FOR THE
BUT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTEEN IN I THANK THE CENTER
FOR LONG BEACH COURSE FOR PRE
THE RESOLUTION FOR BUT ALSO.
ENUMERATING THE REST AND ITEMS
FOR FIVE OF THE SAUCE CAN.
MIDDLE JUST SENATORS FIFTEEN.
BUT WE'RE OUR STAR HIS ORGAN OF
WITH THE FOR HOME OR SHORT
AVENUE URGES FIVE MIN AWAY FROM
MY OWN HOME ASSEMBLY TO IN THE
STILL ON OF ORDINARY EVERY.
WITH A MORE BUT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. OF BUT ALSO- TO A
KNOWLEDGE BE REFERENCED THE CAL
CHURCH WHICH IS CALLED EARLIER
GUADALUPE. BUT WHICH HAD ON ITS
PRIME. BUT DON'T HALL THE FIRST
ORGANIZE HALL OF THE MOVEMENT-
TO THE LARGEST IT IS A STATE
MON- ED THANKS TO THE UPPER. OF
MEMBERS OF THE SLUDGE AND OTHER
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY SAN CLARA
AND WHY THE IS KNOWN MONUMENT
AGAIN RESIDING IN THE HEART OF
MY DISTRICT. KIM IN THE SAME
METAL LEADERSHIP. AS MAHATMA
GANDHI AND DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT. THAT WE
ADOPT THIS RESOLUTION THAT WE
HONOR HIM EVERY YEAR. BECAUSE
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE
EDUCATION THAT HE SPOKE SO
HIGHLY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. IS
NEEDED IN THIS NONVIOLENT
CONTEXT. THANK YOU AN ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW. EACH
OF US IN THIS CHAMBER. BY
VIRTUE OF BEING A MEMBER OF
THIS AUGUST BODY AND
REPRESENTING A MILLION PEOPLE
LIVE AT OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR
LIVES. TO EXPERIENCE
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS TO MEET
LEADERS WHO HAVE GREAT POWER
AND PASSION THE WITNESS GREAT
SPEECHES TO BE INSPIRED BY MANY.
AS A YOUNG TEENAGER. I HAPPEN
TO BE A KID WHO WAS A DRIVER
FOR A WONDERFUL FELLOW BUT A
NUMBER OF THEM DILUTES
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND GOT TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME WHICH SAYS OUR
JOB IS I DON'T REALLY KNOW HIM
WELL. AND HE GENERALLY ABOUT
THE ISSUES. BUT THE REASON I
RISE TODAY. IS BECAUSE AS A
YOUNG TEENAGER AND BEING IN THE
PRESENCE OF THIS PERSON WHO
WASN'T TO SOMEBODY OF GREAT
HEIGHT AND STATURE. HI NOT
STATURE. ON I WITNESSED
SOMEBODY WHO EXERCISED AN
INTERESTING PERSONAL POWER.
ADAPTER HIS EYES QUIETNESS OF
HIS LEADERSHIP. AND GOT TO
WITNESS A NEW KIND OF
LEADERSHIP LEADERSHIP I THINK
THAT IS INFORMED BY THE
SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE ALL SEEN
IN WHAT HE'S DONE. BUT IT WAS
JUST EXTRAORDINARY TO SEE IT
AND IT WAS A GREAT LESSON FOR
SOMEONE LIKE ME AS A YOUNG KID
TO WATCH SOMEBODY EXERCISE THE
KIND OF POWER. BASED UPON
MORALITY AND CONVICTION BASED
UPON DEEP LISTENING TO OTHERS
JUST EXTRAORDINARY EXPERIENCE.
AND SO AT THE TIME CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T HAVE SUCH A SHOPPERS
STAY IN AT THE TIME WAS STILL
FIGHTING THE FIGHT TO THE TIME
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE L. R. B. AND
THE VICTORIES DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BUT I COULD FEEL IT IN MY BONES
THAT WE WERE IN THE PRESENCE OF
SOMEBODY WHO WAS NOTHING LESS
THAN EXTRAORDINARY AND NOT ONLY
DESERVE DESERVES TO GREATNESS
BY VIRTUE OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. BUT BY THE
NATURE OF HIS CHARACTER ASTRI
I'VE- THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN. HEARING NONE
SEEN NINE SENATOR GONZALEZ
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
ALL OF THEIR COMMENTS- I ASK US
TO KEEP FIGHTING FOR OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU.
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. HEARING TíNH NINE.
THIRTY SEVEN ALL EYES ZERO
KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ALONG TO
CONSENT ORDER. WE HAVE ITEMS
FORTY SEVEN TO FIFTY FOUR AND
WE HAVE SPECIAL CONSENT ITEMS
FIFTY FIVE TO SIXTY IS THERE
ANY MEMBER WISHING TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT GALLAGHER.
EIGHTY NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATE BILL.
254-219-2262. THIRTY NINE THREE
OH TWO THREE OH EIGHT THREE
SIXTY NINE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS. FIFTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN THIRTY AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. I AM FORTY SEVENTH.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES. FIVE DECKER FIVE
BORJAS FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTESE HI DALLY
HI DODD. FIVE TERRAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS
FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. BY
HER TADO HI JONES. FIVE
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION HI NEWMAN. I NIELSEN
FIVE A CHIRLA BOTH I PAN HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. HI NUMBER HI LAKE
COUNTY FIVE WIENER. HI WILK.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NOSE IS ZERO
ON FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN OZ
FORTY OZ THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NON MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS TIME.
MISTER BARR PLEASE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT TO A
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEETING WILL CONVENE
AT TEN THIRTY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL COMMIT CONVENE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE AT TEN
THIRTY SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE AT TEN
THIRTY HERE IN THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE HERE IN THE CHAMBER AT
TEN. THIRTY IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS INTERNACIONAIS
JUST AS CLEAR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ARE. I
WISH EACH OF YOU- A RELAXING
AND ENJOY FULL LEGISLATIVE
BREAK COMING YOU'RE DISTRICTS
WITH YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
FAMILY. AND WITH THAT OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY APRIL FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE
SENATE BILL WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH
TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE WE ASK YOU TO HAVE A-
SAFE AND ENJOYABLE HOLIDAY AND
WILL RE CONVENE AGAIN ON.
MONDAY APRIL FIFTH AT TWO PM
THANK YOU MEMBERS.